تعطينا هذه النماذج الأولية من LG Display
إحساسًا بما قد تبدو عليه أجهزة التلفزيون
في المستقبل أو ربما في
المستقبل القريب ، حيث
لا ترى هذه الألوان النابضة بالحياة
تركز على أن هذا كله يتعلق
بإمكانية التنقل بأخذ شاشة
من منزلك  المكتب ولأنه
خفيف جدًا ، يمكنك فقط اصطحابه إلى
مطبخك في غرفة نومك
أينما كانت البيانات التي تحتاجها الشاشة
لتعمل من خلال
كابل USBC واحد ، إنه أمر رائع ، لكن هل من
الضروري أن يقرر المستهلك المستقبلي فقط
أن هذه الشاشة مناسبة  88 بوصة
مكبر الصوت هو أيضًا 88 بوصة وذلك
لأن الشاشة حرفياً هي السماعة
وما تسمح هذه التقنية لهذه الشاشة
بالقيام به هو تحريك الصوت بنسبة 100٪ متزامنة
مع الصورة حتى لا تتمكن من
سماع هذا في المنزل ولكن مثل هذه  الأجسام الغريبة
تتحرك لأعلى ولأسفل ، يمكنني سماع الصوت يتحرك
لأعلى ولأسفل ، ماذا عن التلفاز الشفاف ،
فإن تقنية OLED هذه تعني
أن كل بكسل يخلق ضوءًا خاصًا به
قويًا بما يكفي لجعل هذا
ج  مفهوم تجاري ولكن ماذا لو
كانت هذه ذات يوم نافذة غرفة نومك
[موسيقى]